hey everybody welcome back to css3 in 30
days today is day 15 we're gonna be
coding up a sneaky sidebar what is a
sticky sidebar and why would you use it
well sticky sidebar is essentially just
a sidebar that sticks to the side of the
page as you scroll so that the content
in that sidebar is remains always
visible and the reason why you'd want to
do that is maybe you have an opt-in or a
lead magnet a subscription form a call
to action may be an order purchase maybe
you have a checkout and in the sidebar
has the checkout details with the price
and the taxes and so on and as you're
scrolling down that long page that
sidebar remains in view so that you can
always see important details maybe even
the checkout button something like that
there are some there are a few ideas to
use the sticky sidebar so jump over here
in my browser and let's see what that
looks like here we simply have a info
page we're doing that info page student
page and final page convention that
we've been doing a couple times and
essentially this is just the
instructions with two buttons one takes
to the student version which you're
going to be playing around with and the
final version which you can use for
reference let's go ahead and check what
the final version just to see what's
going on here is the layout we've got a
left side left content with long filler
text and the sidebar as you can see
remains in view and that's kind of
interesting you can position that any
way you really want and if you wanted to
use JavaScript or you wanted to get even
crazier you can wait until you scroll
down until this look this part of the
page and then you have the sticky
sidebar start moving but for this case
we're just gonna use CSS and keep it
simple and just have that sidebar just
remain in its position and it is quite
easy it shouldn't take us very long at
all here's a student version we haven't
done any styles here in terms of laying
out the sidebar sidebars in fact down
here with no Styles whatsoever and it
looks really bad
so let's jump over to our code editor
make sure you download the sticky side
bar number 15 course files and I'll wait
here just a moment for you to go ahead
and do that
[Music]
that should be enough time here in the
code editor I'm going to show you what
the the code looks like real quick and
then I want to get started so the index
file is simply that info page that has
the information with the instructions
you really don't need to concern
yourself with it it is the student HTML
and the final dot HTML are those are the
HTML files that you need to concern
yourself with I'll show you that in a
sec sandbox that CSS is where you're
gonna style things up as usual final
that CSS is where all of the styles are
for you to reference just in case you
need a little bit of help so student
HTML looks like this we have a div with
the class of sticky sidebar lesson we're
gonna use that class in a moment it
wraps everything including the sandbox
div which is the left content and the
sticky side bar div which is the sticky
side bar on the right those are the two
two or three elements that you need to
know and concern yourself with so jump
over into the sandbox at CSS and let's
get ourselves codon code and coding
let's get coding let's a code sticky
side bar - lesson sticky - side bar -
less slash and sticky shared bar lecture
and che with 80% we're gonna say
margin:0 and auto that's just gonna make
those things look a little bit like so
there it is a little bit less wide then
the reason we want to do that is we want
to make some space for some things let's
carry on sticky side bar lesson after
pseudo-element
after virtual last child after element
whatever we want to call that thing the
after display table content empty string
clear:both what is this everybody it is
a okay and that's just simply to allow
the footer to stay put rather than
collapsing up when we start floating the
next element which is the sticky side
bar lesson and then the sandbox we're
gonna style this one up it's gonna be
nice and simple we're gonna give it a
width 60%
and then we're gonna we're gonna
margin:0 0 40 that is 0 on the top 0 1
on left and right 40 on the bottom just
give it some space from the footer and
we're gonna float that left so now if we
save that and check it out footer stays
put and the this content is over on the
left at 60% width sticky sidebar is over
on the right the problem is the sticky
side bar doesn't look right so we're
gonna style it up real nice and Purdy
here so let's scroll down and do one
last set of styles sticky side bar
coming for you sticky side bar
background we're gonna make it that pale
blue color which is e 7f 1 padding 40
pixels 40 pixels 60 pixels that's 40 in
the top 40 in the left and right 60 on
the bottom and we're gonna go box sizing
we're gonna say border box what does
border box do it essentially means that
the padding that you add to the element
doesn't add any width to the box itself
it just maintains that the width that I
determine and the padding stays on the
inside by default when you add padding
to a box it increases the width and that
causes issues when you're doing math for
floating and so on and so forth we want
the box to say the same width that we
determine and the padding on the inside
if this makes any sense whatsoever to to
to maintain the same width but the
padding on the inside stays within their
contained so that's what that does
border radius to pixels a nice little
subtle all the way around we're gonna
give it a box shadow and this is just
going to be an offset 0 12 pixels 0
negative 6 pixels and then F a 9 0 a 3
all that's doing is that little 3d
effect that offset pale blue shadow
makes it look 3d you'll see in a sec
here let's go check it out
there it is it is over here on the right
and it's got that 2 pixel border radius
and then offset shadow but problem the
sticky side bar is that there's no space
in between the two it doesn't look very
good and and that is a problem so let's
go ahead and continue over here we're
gonna say precision position fixed
that's gonna fix it in place but we've
got to tell it where is stay put 5% from
the right the width will be 36% that's
to give it a little bit of a gap between
the sandbox because we don't want it to
be the full width of its of what's left
we want to give it some space from that
sandbox and want to float that right
save that come over here check out the
student version sticky side bar
self-contained when I scroll down it
stays put nice and in place and really
that is it now I have a little challenge
for you if you want to take this a bit
further
outside of the scope of this lesson but
fully something that you should try is
make this responsive currently it is not
responsive so if I resize this we're
just gonna have a sticky side bar that
you know it doesn't look very good the
text isn't right these these shouldn't
be side by side on a mobile device they
should be stacked or the sidebar should
disappear or whatever it is that you
feel necessary I want you to go ahead
add some media queries here in your
sandbox dot CSS and stack these elements
remove the floats remove the
position:fixed do whatever you feel is
necessary to make this look right on
mobile devices I suggest you do that as
a little challenge see what you can come
up with and I hope today's lesson was
valuable to you today hope you have a
few ideas running through your head of
how you might want to use this in your
own projects thanks for hanging out for
a few minutes and I'll see you tomorrow
and day number six